welcome to too hot to handle extra
hot our reunion show can i get a woof
how naughty was this car we're going to be
getting all the goss on what happened once
they return to the real world but all i want
to know is if cam and emily are still together
but in the meantime do our sexy sorts even know
how many rules they broke i don't think they do
there's a lot all the time camera had a crafty
wank in the shower so that was a good full grand
spent how could i forget the crab grab crap crap
frog crab crab yeah he was like doing something
in her in her pants and it was like noises
going on emily was like listen now where is cam
oh melinda obviously marvin uh sex it was
something else i think there was someone else
i think a hand job as well which i heard the whole
night yes and myself and robert came in and i was
five six yeah cam and christina in the private
room did i say ken no robert and christina kevin
christina he wishes yeah kiss chase i remember we
might as well file for bankruptcy at this point i
feel like i got the mole true lawyer i never
forget a rule break here is the couple behind
half of those rule breaks and one of them still
managed to win the show it's marvin and melinda
so marvin you won congratulations yes do
you think you're going to share the money
when you receive the money i have no idea
what i'm gonna do for you this is your money
i don't want any drop of the of the money you've
earned it do you know what you're gonna spend the
money on i gotta share like um like half of it
with my mom first like that's the first thing
and then i'm gonna see you like with what's
left but my mom is like the most important
person i'm sure everyone else is dying to
know as am i what happened after the show
you guys want to tell me i'm thinking well we've
got a technical issue guys like come on sorry out
we were supposed to meet in tulum in mexico i
booked my flight to go there and we fought and
like finally i didn't go so yeah melinda i can see
you're holding your tongue right now girl we were
supposed to be in mexico that's correct i booked
the airbnb i had things planned but of course marv
and i did get into an argument that is true but he
could have put his big boy pants on and still came
but he decided to cancel his whole flight the day
that he was supposed to come i was trying to text
him he was ignoring my text i was texting chase
ignoring me too oh i was left in the dark i was
pissed and then he goes to mexico a month later
yeah month later i i went with chase well i mean
i would have just taken advantage of that melinda
and be like you know what i'm just going to go
with the girls i was just so sad i honestly i just
want to be at that point i want to be by myself
i was just kind of just a heartbroken that a small
argument would make him counsel the whole trip
that i was really looking forward to like seeing
him so for a long time we didn't talk or anything
and but like now we're talking and like we're in
good terms and i don't know what's gonna happen
but like we'll see his favorite line we'll see
so just to clarify are you still together or not
we're not together anymore even though i
do miss her a lot i still and will always
have love for marvin that's undeniable like i'm
still attracted to him i still have love for him
it would be oh the wrong way you gotta kiss
him that way yeah i think that was someone else
oh my god it was such a joy talking to you
both i think we should watch your best bits
sexy hot steamy this guy is hot
i like it i think we're going to
lose money tonight melinda and me
yesterday yeah it was a
perfect moment i kissed peter
this is the game you chose to play and now i'm
playing right back at you you were topless and
he was touching your butt hell no i'm so too a
little bit no you exactly you talk to her a little
bit and that's a lot i should have treat you the
way i treat my mom oh you know yeah all i know is
what i say to you guys and that i like marvin
it is not just about sex no rules were broken
way deeper there is a real connection and
yeah i can really see myself with that girl
we couldn't touch each other or anything and
i think that has brought us closer than ever
now if there's one thing the villa
proves it's that people are complicated
and one woman knows this
more than most it's larissa
i love you i love you too the feeling is mutual
complicated that's like a nice way to just put
crazy your exit was such a shock to me honestly
i was sad to see you go i really was i was like
that's the result how did you feel on the planet
i felt like at peace coming home i didn't feel sad
or like normally i'd be like out drinking with
my friends and being full if that had happened
but instead i was like sitting there thinking
about what lana had taught me and what i'd learned
so it was probably a really good thing for me
actually what were the main reasons that you left
i don't know i just woke up one day and to me the
retreat felt like a bit different like everyone i
was closest with had gone home like christina and
robert had just gone home and i just felt like
a bit out of place i was worried it was going
to become this like larissa versus elfin which
like it never was but it felt like it like i'd go
into the bedroom and it felt like it was all like
are you seeing anyone now good i am seeing
someone he's amazing yeah he's really amazing
he's a doctor so we're a bit of power couple um
and he's just really sweet and funny and fun and
just like obsessed with me and i'm obsessed with
him but he's so obsessed with me and i love it
yeah i do shove my face in it all the time i
look more than i've seen chloe in regards to
to you and nathan have you spoke since the show
are you on good terms like what's going on yeah
so we spoke when i came out he gave me a call
um that conversation was a lot better than the
one that we entered it on but then i got some
weird drunk messages which i wasn't a fan oh
you got some weird messages i mean like were they
positive negative it was like a drunk like show
me your tits kind of oh okay after everything i
was like fun bags yeah yeah babe i'm literally
just about to speak to nathan and l so i'm gonna
have to let you go but i love your millions thank
you so much for talking to me i can't wait for you
to see it bye cheers to one l of a date oh my god
i heard that come on l right now is just looking
amazing she looks she looks incredible needless
to say like nathan turns me on like you can't
stop giggling you go oh my god it's because i'm
so horny yeah this is definitely more second
date kind of language nathan your love life
journey in the villa is had more twists and turns
than my iphone cable where was your head at when
you went on that date with elle so larissa and i
she was a tough cookie man like i just could not
i couldn't break it down i don't know what it
is i know she she's a lawyer herself so uh i
think she's so set on following rules and i'm
usually not elle came along as soon as she rode
in she crashed that jet ski i was like yes amazing
entrance by the way l oh my goodness that was now
most graceful entrance el you were so composed
driving in and then i think you saw me is what
it was and then you just you just lost it you
just don't flatter yourself i don't know like
maybe the sunlight was hitting them like really
nice and i just saw him first and i was like
larissa was standing there though weren't she all
of us guys jumped up straight away i went to l
chase went straight to tabitha and i knew directly
behind me both emily and larissa were just
would just burn in a hole in my back was it
awkward it was only awkward because larissa like
every time she saw me like gave me daggers she was
like there you know i was like she's freaking out
larissa left i mean how do you feel on that
was it easy i don't want to say that i was
the reason that she left because it wasn't i
did feel a little guilty at the time because
you know i tried to say goodbye to her and she
just she just pushed me away and said like have
a great time and walked off so i knew that there
was a lot of animosity between the two of us um
do i feel guilty no was it easier
yes i've literally just jumped off
of a call with larissa you and her have you spoke
since are you okay good terms civil yeah okay
yeah so we uh we you know what when we first
got home we spoke a lot we facetimed a lot um
i don't know what's going on in her personal
life but um we're very close we you know there's
there's things that she's messaged me that uh
she would like to do that we didn't do so uh
have you met anyone else not text me back so
i had to move on from that one that's a figure
you know what i've just kind of
been enjoying doing me i'm no longer
a stripper so that's a good thing for me hung
up my d stream it's not a g string but you
know what i mean you will be expecting
a message from me after this interview
i'm joking jesus i'm all right
ouch have you got a new tattoo
i have indeed no i can't no i can't i
can't even deal i can't right chlorine
i'm taking my shirt off right now oh my
god no no don't make it awkward for me no
stop it oh my god don't i just want to lick him
nathan you i'm trying to
do a job here it's been so
lovely talking to you and hopefully i'll see
your lovely faces very soon let me tell you it
can be pretty awkward staying in the villa
with the guy things didn't work out with
and this lot know just as well as me you're gonna
be able to say anything you want to chase anything
that's been burning inside of you that you haven't
been able to say aol first of all i think you have
a huge ego i don't even know who you are i don't
know if what we had was ever true i think you
lied to me i think you were really manipulative i
think you were with me for not the right reasons
you make me feel not confident you
never made me feel good about myself
i had asked you the whole time to be affectionate
with me as soon as someone else walked in the
door you were affectionate that night i
left crying and you knew how sad i was
and you never came out and asked how i was you
did not care i was sick to my stomach over you
moving on so quickly you're not nice you're
not nice guys my babies pick up the season
too was it the first time you've ever been
gagged or have you been ganked before yeah
she loves it this is the family show
don't get me wrong if you think carly's
the first girl to ever you know [ __ ]
me out like that i'd be lying to you but
most of the time i could just hit that do
not disturb button and never deal with it
how did that feel when you let that all
out good i felt really good after and like
i remember like a couple days went by i thought
i would always feel like some way for chase and i
got over a lot quicker and then also obviously
joey helped um enjoy's the best rebound
we call it an upgrade geez no matter how awkward
you thought that was let's never forget about
this moment she's in me that i didn't even know
i had same hair yeah i feel like i haven't felt
oh my god cockroaches landed on my forehead
that scared the [ __ ] out of me wow lana
what do the rules say about a cockroach sitting
on your face how funny is that oh my god
right in the middle was it a cockroach
do we know if it was a cockroach or not i
think it was a cockroach i just remember
when it happened i was dying laughing
oh my god that's some symbolism
you obviously smelt like [ __ ]
on season one when we finished filming
we had a little group chat on instagram
called lana is bae do you use keeping contact
are you frequently in touch with each other
what's the deal i would say i would say yeah uh
i know they have a group chat that i'm not in
but uh joey and carly and i we all spent uh new
year's together and then i went back you know
end of january and hung out with them a little bit
more so i talked to tabitha um quite often as well
as soon as you mentioned tabitha tabitha your face
changed after the show we spoke a lot i think he
sent me like a really cute i think he sent me
like flowers and stuff for christmas and chop
he sent me some really cool oh he wrote
me a love letter like confessing his love
to me which is so sweet and i still haven't
done it is that what you said okay can we all go
did you say i'm going to get the love letter i'm
going to read it get it read it we want to hear it
no we need to see it no tab i thought honestly
but you know the distance got in the way between
us i think literally been celebrated for
four months now we need proof proof is in
the vagina have you actually met up no well he
was supposed to put me like a big procrastinator
and um you know i just never got around to it so
i kind of hold on hold on hold on last i checked
tab was coming to see me for new year's and
the next morning she was in dubai so i don't
have you been seeing anyone after the show um
after the show i went to miami to see joey i
stayed there for like i don't even know how long
i actually went back three times you didn't answer
my question you're avoiding it are you are you
seeing anyone um right now no no me and joey talk
i see the look in carly's eyes every time
i talk to her oh my god guys do you know
what i think it's time to put you back in the
villa because you clearly need more bloody help
it's been so lovely talking to all of you thank
you so much for taking the time to talk to me
i'm too hot to handle extra hot whoa
it has been so hard so you're banning me go away
so when like our snowbees come in as
more options did anything change for you
i made the mistake of light with christina yeah
i can't make that mistake do i think chase's
boyfriend material i think he should be more
concerned about me being girlfriend material
so nice challenge yeah very nice
chat just gonna get naked in here
there are two people we just have
to bring in here it's coming emily
what would it have taken to have got
you in that shower i need to know
not in the retreat if she wasn't in the scenario
obviously it definitely would have got in the
shower but you did resist and i'm proud of you
thank you that means a lot i'm proud of myself you
know i heard about this shower scenario through
carly i am very surprised he didn't get in the
shower i mean i would have yeah i guess i'm just
not too happy about how much he contemplated it
like it should have been just a absolute straight
up no but he like walked up and down for ages like
really had to think about it yeah especially what
we've already been through with christina normally
if a girl asked me to get the shower i should get
in the shower i don't have to think oh i've got
this other girl here that i actually care about
so throughout the whole show you just blossomed
and if i say so myself you you were
my favorite couple in the retreat
cam you said i love you i wanted to say it for a
while because that's what i felt but i was like
i kind of wanted it to be our thing i didn't
want to make a big like song or dance about it
oh do you what's so funny actually when he told
me he loved me i didn't hear him he had to say it
three times before i actually heard what he said
i know how much of a deep kid he is and i know he
meant that 100 i'm gonna ask the golden question
are you guys still together yeah yeah we are okay
oh my god i'm so happy yeah we have literally
been like inseparable since we got home so we
came home she came to mind for a bit and then i
basically went i packed everything up and moved
in with them so we're now living together we've
literally haven't spent many days apart since the
show so yeah obviously you've only just come
out of lockdown so we went on our first day
um not too long ago which was actually
really weird he just sees me every day
in my dressing gown like i don't dress up
i don't do anything i'm just complete slob
so why are you still with me i have no idea we're
essentially like a little married couple now
like we know a lot we know everything about
each other and you're allowed to have sex
when we first came back i did you not we were
having sex like seven times a day every day
so she came to see me at my um at my flat
and i was living my housemate at the time
and he even said to me he was like i'm
thinking a bit worried about you he's like
it's a lot he's like you're going at it a lot he's
like are you both right i was like yeah yeah we're
fine we just like each other so what's what's next
in your relationship i mean is there wedding bells
do you do you listen together yeah yes we live
together now and yeah and obviously whether
bells are definitely on the cards for me like i'm
cracking on a bit i need to be thinking about that
um also if we have a baby girl
we're going to call her lana
well hang on a second you have a baby
girl no if you don't wait i have a baby
well your walls are the same color which
means you're in the same building now why
you want separate cameras that's a good question
go and join each other i want to see you come on
together not like on screen upstairs you look like
the perfect couple i'm not gonna lie go on give us
a little kiss come on wow have you practiced any
lord of the rings sexual activities in the bedroom
yet no i feel like that's not something we'll
do that is where i draw the line no elf costumes
no i don't really like all of it yeah no i feel
like that is a definitely definite turn off pam
please can we hear you do a gollum impersonation
i'm so happy to show my love oh i found myself
it's been lovely speaking to you girls
i love you good stuff good start i love a happy
ending and speaking of good times i asked the cast
what their favorite memories were
of the villa my favorite moment
marvin and i on the couch chatting and we
shared our first kiss because i felt like
i really got to know him definitely like all
the parties also it wasn't the day with me
uh all the dancing with me and marvin that's
probably my favorite i would say the food was
unreal the entire time i think everybody can
agree with that the arrival on the jet skis the
adrenaline i had like it literally was something
out of a movie i get to wake up every morning
next to robert just chuckling away camp to my
right and i get to be sleeping next to like all
my best friends and their girlfriends so uh that
was my opportunity and i loved every minute of it
to follow that nate bloody hell
mate what a tear-jerker that was hey
you just got my favorite moment and job
my favorite favorite memory was the
absolute first party probably me and
emily becoming friends i really love her so much
and larissa we became like this really tight trio
it probably has to be our final day and
you know just the setting was so beautiful
the food was good we had a bottle of wine and
he asked me to be his girlfriend on global tv
no more crafts become just like focus on this
one girl so for me it was it was definitely
that i think first and foremost was the steamy
kiss with christina i mean that was top at the
top of the range stuff that was he actually
flew straight straight to south africa after
the show we were on something crazy together just
brought us so close to something that we shared
that was just mental it just clicked straight
away you know yeah we just we are so similar
yet so different but i love him robert normally
gets to go and that's the cat this is the
the case this time we've spilled the tea i've
done my first presenting job it's been a blast
i'm chloe and thank you so much for
watching we'll see you next time
you